the rebels are here in vast numbers and
they're celebrating but this is not an
outright victory for them yes after the
jubilation overnight and through the
morning Tripoli remains tense dangerous
and in nobody's control this is one of a
growing number of Gaddafi's military
bases impenetrable for months but now
firmly in the hands of rebels loyalists
are being rounded up throughout the city
but hundreds on both sides have been
killed and injured the rebels have been
moving so fast they have no idea what
lies ahead plays last card if you
forsake his last game and even he's the
color in his army they lose control so
older the army of Gaddafi now they fight
without any order without anything it's
almost impossible to get a clear picture
of the level of Gaddafi resistance there
are many cameras following the rebel
advance but none with access to the
other side not far from here is the
Rick's also fell where journalists have
covered the conflict under government
restrictions but that area is still
under the control of the regime those
inside reports heavy fighting
until the rebels are edging around the
city taking control of former Gaddafi
checkpoints removing his green flag and
raising their own people are sounding
their horns now a lot of the vehicles
that are passing us are carrying rebel
fighters and they've got rebel flags on
them but a lot of vehicles are also
coming from the heart of the city with
families who don't appear to be
connected to the rebels they are
ordinary families from Tripoli who are
waving to us who are shouting down with
Gaddafi who were shouting freedom and
Libya and over there when a checkpoint
is you would hear the occasional bursts
of gunfire but it's a albin in
celebration so far some of these are
families who had to keep quiet for
months now they have a voice of their
city is still a terrifying place for
them to live